acerca de esos 700 millones de pesos que
el gobierno quiere usar para comprar el
suceder y salvar la economía el gobierno
ha estado hablando muchísimo del hecho
de que al comprar sucede os no estamos
simplemente escribiendo lees un cheque a
los accionistas estamos comprando
activos por más apestosos que sean y
quién sabe tal vez incluso ganamos
dinero con ellos yo he estado diciendo y
muchas otras personas también han estado
diciendo que eso es muy improbable
porque esos activos muy probablemente
valen mucho menos que lo que el gobierno
va a pagar por ellos de hecho uno puede
argumentar porque muchos de ellos no
valen nada he recibido algunas cartas
preguntándome que cómo pueden valer cero
eso sucede o si son activos que están
respaldados por hipotecas las cuales a
su vez están respaldadas por casas y
bueno en este vídeo voy a dar un ejemplo
muy claro y directo para que veamos por
qué algunas veces de estos cds o sea de
estas obligaciones de deuda
colateralizada podrían valer muy poco o
incluso
no valer nada así es que hagamos algo
sencillo no hablemos de millones de
casas
hablemos nada más de 10 casas y ofrecer
10 créditos hipotecarios de llamas que
cada hipoteca es de un millón de pesos
y entonces tenemos 10 casas ya cada una
de ellas les vamos a dar
un millón de pesos
bueno para dar estos préstamos lo que
hacemos es crear una compañía una
corporación una entidad de propósito
especial ok
esta es la hoja de balance de la
compañía
estos son los activos que tenemos
activos pues de activos tenemos
10 millones de pesos repartidos en 10
hipotecas de 1 millón de pesos cada una
y bueno estas hipotecas tienen una
garantía un colateral el cual es la casa
que se compró con ese crédito
hipotecario y como consiguió el dinero
esta entidad del propósito especial que
es bueno que les parece si le llamamos
de entidad del propósito especial bueno
pero como consiguió dinero esta
corporación pues las personas que
compraron estos tebeos estas
obligaciones de deuda colateralizada
pusieron todo el dinero y eso es lo que
son las obligaciones de deuda
colateralizada deuda que se usa para
financiar otras cosas en este caso
hipotecas lo que haríamos en los títulos
grande hipotecaria es crear mil acciones
y entonces cada acción tiene una
milésima parte de este valor y además
cada acción está aportando la misma
cantidad de dinero pero en las
obligaciones de deuda colateralizada lo
que hacemos es dividirlo en pedazos
digamos que lo divido en tres franjas
aquí está una franja
y está la otra franja y finalmente la
última franja y entonces voy con otras
personas y pregunto quiénes quieren
prestar dinero para las hipotecas y de
esos 10 millones de pesos que se
prestaron a los créditos hipotecarios
digamos que el 50 por ciento o sea 5
millones quieren que su dinero esté muy
seguro quieren tener la preferencia en
cuestión de seguridad que les paguen
primero a ellos para que si sale algo
mal sean los demás los que se quedan sin
dinero entonces quieren pertenecer a
esta franja que es la más segura a la
que llamamos senior o también le
llamamos con derechos prioritarios y
para que ellos lleguen a perder algo de
su dinero o sea para que les paguen
menos dinero del que prestaron los que
están en esta franja o en esta otra
tienen que perder todo su dinero así es
que la compañía ep toma 5 millones de
pesos de otras personas ya ellas les va
a pagar un interés más bajo porque están
en la franja más segura y bueno estas
diez hipotecas me faltó decirlo
pero están pagando un 8% de interés así
es que a esta franja le voy a pagar yo
creo que un 5% y por qué están
dispuestos a aceptar una tasa de interés
tan baja
pues porque si alguien no paga su
hipoteca eso les va a afectar a estas
franjas mucho antes de lo que les podría
afectar a esta o sea estas dos franjas
se tienen que quedar completamente sin
su capital inicial para que les llega a
afectar en algo a los que están en esta
franja
así es que podríamos decir que estos son
instrumentos de deuda muy seguros y
bueno digamos que el pp toma
4 millones de pesos prestados a las
personas en esta franja a ellos les
tiene que pagar un interés más alto les
tienen que pagar no sé digamos que el 6%
porque están arriesgando más que los de
esta franja entonces la recompensa tiene
que ser mayor y finalmente toma un
millón de pesos de esta franja las
personas que están en esta franja son
los que están dispuestos a correr la
mayor parte del riesgo así es que si
alguien no paga su deuda estos van a ser
los primeros afectados y antes de que le
afecte a alguien más en otra de las
franjas y estas personas se van a quedar
sin su capital inicial sin su 1 millón
de pesos que le dieron a esta compañía y
bueno podemos averiguar cuál es la tasa
de interés que le tenemos que pagar a
los que están en esta franja cuánto
dinero está recibiendo el pp antes de
que nadie deje de pagar su crédito
hipotecario pues los que sacaron el
crédito les están pagando 8 por ciento
de interés al mes
entonces cuánto dinero está recibiendo
efe al mes
está recibiendo de los 10
millones que les prestó a los créditos
hipotecarios está recibiendo el 8 por
ciento ok entonces está recibiendo 800
mil pesos al mes aunque está recibiendo
800 mil pesos al mes pero pues los
tienes que pagar el 5 por ciento a los
que están en esta franja
así es que bueno esta franja puesto 25
millones ok de sus 5 millones tienen que
pagar el 5 por ciento o sea que les
tiene que pagar 250 mil
- 250000 que les tienen que pagar a
estos y ahora veamos cuánto les tiene
que pagar a los que están en esta franja
pues los que están en esa franja
prestaron
4 millones y les tiene que pagar el 6
por ciento o sea que les tiene que pagar
240 mil pesos menos 240 mil pesos
así es que 800 menos estas cantidades
esta resta nos queda de 310 mil entonces
de los intereses que están llegando a ep
una vez que ya les pagamos a las dos
franjas de abajo nos quedan 310 mil
pesos y eso se los tenemos que pagar la
franja de hasta arriba pero ellos nos
prestaron un millón de pesos entonces
esto o sea 310 mil es el 31 por ciento
de lo que ellos nos prestaron si se
multiplican un millón por punto 31 les
va a quedar 310 mil entonces la tasa de
interés de la franja de hasta arriba
antes de que nadie deje de pagar su
crédito hipotecario es del 31 por ciento
y eso de que les den el 31 por ciento
suena maravilloso son a padres
y tal vez por eso le llaman franja de
capital pero también se están
arriesgando muchísimo y también le
llaman tramo de renta variable y bueno
un año después
algunas de estas diez personas que
sacaron su crédito hipotecario terminan
de pagar toda su hipoteca déjame borro
esto para que no nos estorbe entonces
pongamos la hoja de balance del pp
dentro de un año y aquí están los
activos y estos son los pasivos de
pasivos tenemos los préstamos de las
personas que compran los vídeos
esa es la franja más segura esta es la
franja de en medio de 4 millones y hasta
arriba la franja de capital o tramo de
renta variable que son los que más se
arriesgan entonces digamos que después
de un año digamos que la mitad de las
personas terminan de pagar su hipoteca
entonces nos dan 5 millones de regreso
ya ver en esta hoja de balance este lado
son los activos
y este lado son los pasivos y hay vídeos
acerca de cómo funcionan las hojas de
balance si no te acuerdas puedes
regresar a ellas y en esta hoja de
balance no hay capital al menos en esta
hoja no había capital porque los activos
serán igual a los pasivos y el propósito
de esta entidad del propósito especial
es simplemente proporcionar una
estructura para poder tener estos cds y
hacer estos préstamos aunque muy
probablemente el banco que creó esta
compañía si tenía un montón de capital y
bueno en esta hoja de balance tampoco va
a haber capital porque sigue siendo una
entidad de propósito especial entonces
estas personas fueron maravillosas fue
buenísimo haberles dado el crédito
hipotecario ellos están felices porque
compraron sus casas de un millón de
pesos y nosotros estamos felices porque
ya obtuvimos de regreso a nuestro dinero
y nos pagaron intereses sin embargo hay
otras personas que no pagaron su
hipoteca pero no todo está perdido
porque estas hipotecas tenían una
garantía un colateral que son las casas
que compraron con ese millón de pesos
que los prestan
entonces damos y anulamos la hipoteca y
pues tenemos que quitarles la casa para
recuperar el dinero y tratamos de vender
esas casas pero desafortunadamente sólo
logramos conseguir el 60 por ciento de
su valor original entonces tenemos aquí
5 millones y el 60% pues terminan siendo
3 millones entonces logramos recuperar 3
millones y entonces llega la hora de la
repartición los que están en esta franja
recolectan su dinero primero porque
justo por eso aceptaron obtener una tasa
de interés más baja para que fueran a
ellos a los primeros a los que les
regresaran su dinero entonces a ellos
les regresan sus 5 millones de pesos
entonces todos estos 5 millones se van
directamente a pagarles a esta franja ok
y después de eso les tenemos que pagar
la segunda franja y eso ya no es tan
padre porque aunque ellos nos prestaron
4 millones de pesos sólo quedan 3
millones de pesos que van directamente a
pagar su préstamo entonces ellos reciben
3 millones de pesos
terminan perdiendo un millón de pesos
entonces después de un año sin tomar en
cuenta los intereses que recibieron
ellos terminan recuperando tres cuartas
partes de su capital inicial de lo que
le prestaron a esta entidad del
propósito especial o sea terminan
recuperando 75 centavos de cada peso que
le prestaron y aquí viene la parte más
importante de este ejemplo qué pasa con
estas personas con este ese veo que
prestó un millón de pesos pero una tasa
de interés del 31 por ciento pues ya no
hay dinero para regresarle su préstamo o
sea ya no había dinero ni siquiera para
terminar de pagarle a esta franja que
tenía prioridad en cuestión de seguridad
entonces estos no van a recibir nada de
su dinero la verdadera pregunta es qué
tipo de estadios son las que tienen
todos estos bancos en sus hojas de
balance si son este tipo de ceos
entonces son severos muy seguros y
entonces pues muy probablemente los
bancos no tienen ningún problema
definitivamente no van a quebrar
seguramente hay un montón de personas
que los quieren
y de hecho los bancos muy probablemente
no quieren deshacerse de ellos si lo que
hay en las hojas de balances de los
bancos son este otro tipo de ese dios
pues la verdad es que no están en tantos
problemas no en las hojas de balance que
vimos tenían dos millones de c2 y pues
si recuperan 75 centavos por cada peso
entonces definitivamente no van a
quebrar esos bancos y que el gobierno
llegue y compre estos activos tampoco es
tan mala idea pero la verdad es que lo
más probable es que los activos que se
encuentran en las hojas de balances son
este tipo de ese de dos porque no hay
tantas personas que quieran comprar
estos dedos y los bancos generalmente no
se pueden deshacer de ellos y si el
gobierno llegara y los comprara estaría
comprando un activo que vale cero